[Music]
the real definition of envy could be
Spain
[Applause]
that is a really good way of thinking
about it it's contrasting easy to find
and easy to prove for two different
notions easy to find the proof easy to
prove something it's very thanks thanks
the question said that way it's
philosophically very interesting I think
that actually is from computer
scientists was really an intellectual
understanding of the difference
I agree yes so - thanks thanks for your
comment then all right
obviously I I work on this I saw you
know I there are there are the 17
different ways of explaining things and
for this audience I had made a choice or
you think is around you know you're
probably right
so excellent let's go ahead with with
the perceptive the perceptron algorithm
and that's that sort of a familiar
concept obviously right I mean oh so
it's what what you are what what you are
given
so basically it you know going beyond
online problems where you don't have an
input but so you know but your face
facing a priori situation every time
what cat happens all we know is that is
that is that you want to learn the
distribution okay you want to learn some
kind of point distribution and and sort
of you know the sad fact is that we know
how to do it one thing and that's
learn learn planes ok hyper planes that
we know how to do well and so you know
and and and I'm going to present this
because it's an extremely simple
algorithm so you are given you know you
are promised that you're big you I'm
going to give you a set of examples okay
and and they all come from you know all
the positive examples come from one half
of the space and what the negative
examples have from another half of the
space okay that's the problems all right
and they say they have the hyperplane
goes to zero and everything all of these
Sorvino can be reduced to this simple
case we know that the pluses and the
minuses are separated by hyperplane
so we know you can think of it as the
vector is is the characteristics of of
emails so we know and the plus or minus
is it spam is it not spam okay you know
something like that I mean really but
let me know that this problem is easy
because you are told that there is a
hyperplane that defines it occasionally
no real problems are not like that
okay but let's solve this problem and
see what you can do and in fact there is
some positive number M which gives you a
margin okay in other words if you tweak
the hyperplane a little okay it's still
going to be good it's still going to
separate okay you know there is a margin
all right now so that's that's what we
are given and I'm going to show you how
to solve this and we know because it's
it's a the algorithm is extremely simple
you are looking for this hyperplane you
start with a bad guess and you update it
for its example if you make you will
have a false positive you add it if you
have a false negative you subtract it
from W okay and the theorem says that
even hyperplane exists it will be found
after a but most one over the margin
square mistakes okay so that's this is
this is the theorem it has a very simple
proof and it sort of okay it solves that
you know it solves a problem
it's sort of an embarrassing easy
problem right let me know because
because in real life but I mean oh there
isn't why I'm bothering you with this is
because it's the beginning of a glorious
story right I mean oh so we have known
this scene that since the fifties
sixties and of course we know that
usually pluses and minuses are not
separated by hyperplanes right I'm you
know so what do you do this and there is
a beautiful trick that you can use here
and I'm going to do something that
requires courage so please bear with me
because I'm going to show you a video
okay okay so I guess I'm going to search
for so the way I found it because
because I'm sure that you want to play
it again I typed on Google kernel trick
YouTube okay so here's what it gets you
okay this is these are some some blue
points separated from the red points by
a circle or item you know like the ones
I showed you and obviously there is no
there is no hyperplane that but then if
you add this funk this third dimension
okay
chosen carefully look what happens the
blue points and the red points can be
separated okay because that because the
because the the third dimension helps
okay that's that's the point and this is
what makes this is this is what makes
this is what makes this this perceptron
algorithm because it can be it can be
enhanced by these functions okay these
functions have to be in some sense of
positive definite okay
in a very well defined analytical way
and so the way that you know it became
sort of in a very interesting idea very
interesting industries core support
vector machines and that is that if you
have a data set that looks very
difficult if you come at stop and think
and you come up with some entry a bunch
of interesting functions that you cannot
do this to this do the dimensionality of
the problem if you are lucky and you
know or if you have the magic okay so
you know because because this is also an
art to find the right functions then you
you are going to get the perceptron
algorithm sudden is going to work work
okay so you know and with with the same
with the same complexity as that simple
perceptron algorithm or a so that this
is this is sort of you know very
interesting very interesting fact and
the support vector machines were a huge
thing here are a huge wave of success
for for artificial intelligence until of
course they were dwarfed you know by who
dignity merit okay you know so so and
and and they were so you know there was
you know a glorious history of success
you know the last half decade or so
alright I'm you know more and more
amazing problems solved by deep Nets
including vision including speech
alright so just to touch on what is the
kind of problems that we can attack by
deep nets I'm going to I'm going to tell
you a few things about sort of you know
the other you know the more general form
of of supervised learning okay so and
the question is imagine that we want one
sir to answer the question or to
classify apples into tasty and non tasty
ok and as we know this depends on the
color of the Apple and of the diameter
of the Apple alright so and let's assume
it does all right let me know that this
is enough to deter
all right we know so and so let's see
let's see what is this problem I mean oh
what is what how do you define this
mathematically essentially you are given
a distribution all right let me know
that but these are these apples are good
these apples are not so good right I
mean oh so you are given a distribution
sorry you'll give the distribution of
all labeled examples right let me know
that that that this is sort of you know
more more likely to be in this release
in this elongated ellipse parra done
than the others and then you are given
you know you are looking for labeled
examples there is some hypothetical
function that map's points on the plane
to good or bad sample from this
distribution and basically what you want
now is you have a class of learning
hypothesis okay you have an idea of what
is the shape of good apples okay and
imagine that we feel that the shape of
good apples is is a rectangle right I
mean also you are looking for you know
your space of hypothesis is the space of
all the rectangles and you are looking
for the best rectangle to fill your data
okay that's this is this is you know
this is the kind of problem that I want
to discuss next so very briefly and is
it clear so you know I want everybody to
understand so you know it's it's it's
you have a distribution from which you
get good and bad apples labeled that's
why it's called supervised triangle
because nature helps you sort of you
know you know every time you have got in
doubt you can solve you can say let's
let's go to the supermarket to get
another you have you have and you have a
class of learning hypothesis in other
words what is your goal what is your
what is your the shape of your of your
of your that you are seeking of
understanding what it means to be a good
Apple okay and the goal is what is
called the learning theory probably
approximately correct so we know it
it's a it's a it's a beautiful phrase
tossed by less valium story neither
nineteen eighties and and basically what
we want to do is we want to select one
of the hypothesis H such that probably
you probably do mines that are some
small tender it's approximately correct
okay
so you want to find the hypothesis which
is probably approximately correct and
one an important question that comes to
mind okay that that that classified
sensor these problems to harder and
easier is these box hypothesis this
rectangle rectangle hypothesis do you
know that you're good apples are in a
box and the bad rappers are outside the
box or this is sort of you know you have
to restrict your state of hypothesis and
that's how we did okay so and of course
the second case or we know where you are
not sure that the good double-side in
the box
okay so the domain of the first
probability is basically the
randomisation randomisation you are
going to run out onto my diagram here
sigh please yeah so it's you are going
to run a lot of mind algorithm and you
want to you want to okay you want to use
randomization of a robber okay so I
wrote the book on this okay so you know
I'm very writing right now okay now all
right so here is that will draw from
this distribution a sample of labeled
points of the form X plus or minus very
simple find the hypothesis H in H in H
in your classic hypothesis that
minimizes the number of misclassified
pointers okay
what were to do is to tell you how big
it is because that's only the only thing
I want to tell you right I mean oh
because otherwise that we're going to
draw it by by by chance right and and
how to solve this problem okay and these
are of course are the $60,000 questions
these how hard it's all to solve this
problem is the hardest of the two okay
so I'm not going to talk about it often
this problem is np-complete often it's
np-complete but can be solved by by by
backpropagation okay bye-bye gradient
descent explained biblically very well
okay so I'm not going to address this
it's it's it's it's a deep question but
I'll show you the theorems you have
about the size of s okay what is what is
what is what s is is is again my goal
here is to give you a very very short
sort of smattering of results you
haven't learned any theory and here here
are the theorems we have I realized
learning theorems is ambiguous I mean
theorems about learning oh yeah yeah
okay so I'm not requiring you to learn
this theorem sorry
so under the alias ability assumption
but many samples are suffice okay so if
you know that your apples are in boxes
okay and you have a set of boxes to try
then and you know that in one of these
boxes is the right answer then you need
to have that many you know in other
words you see it's it's a it's a it's a
it's a decreasing function of epsilon
and Delta both and an increasing
function of the size of H the other is a
pair without realizability roughly
speaking we need more samples
essentially by a factor of 1 over
epsilon K so you need many more examples
if because epsilon has to be like 1% so
you need maybe thousands times more
examples and the logarithm of the size H
can be replaced they're both by
fascinating set theoretic concept called
the vapnik chair Bernanke's dimension ok
the VC dimension which essentially says
how sophisticated is your age okay if I
give you K points will you be able and I
give you some partition I want this to
be Plus this will be minus will you be
able to find an H that does this ok I
can you do it for any set of K points
then your VC dimension is bigger okay
all right so this is my this is my sort
of quick quick very quick there are many
beautiful books on learning the more
theoretical one that I know is a very
early one by by Karen sympathy Ronnie
and the size book is an amazing book so
you know it's called understanding
learning theory how do you put the title
my ciliary yes I had Sally machine that
so and and I didn't have it when I in
front of me I have it in Colombia when
when I prepare this talk but but I try
to rip to to recall it okay so um great
excellent so now I'm going to tell you
about the fascinating subject which is
computational as the less of the science
so what I want to tell you what I want
to convince you is that engagement with
neuroscience is not our first bout okay
we you know we have we have a long
history of enjoy engaging with other
sighs ok you know and and and I'm going
to show you sort of you know and what
does it mean the computational edge of
the sciences ok remember the first my
very you know the first slide about
computer science that I showed you ok
sort of the epoch of solving studying
the computer and solving the engineering
problems associated the computer so this
experience has transformed my field ok
so basically you know we developed a
very special special way of thinking
that's of course mathematically some
sense it's also practical in in in other
cases but definitely it has sort of you
know we call it the algorithmic waiting
at the computational working ok and and
it's it's it's this very distinctive all
right amino so if you we know if you if
you if you watch us talk to one another
so you know you you'll see that we speak
sort of you know in a particular tone ok
you know that is that we call the
computational way of understanding the
world and the point is that this is a
new way of understanding the
world and so occasionally I'm not saying
often I'm not saying most of the time no
but occasionally if if we look at it at
the problem at the heart problem in
another science we have a new idea okay
that's that's my point
all right let me know and and and let me
show you a few a few few examples okay
the first historical example is this or
we know it is is a statistical physics
alright let me know so and the pioneer
in this is is the former associate
director of the same assist acute
Alistair Sinclair my Co my former
colleague at computer science at
Berkeley and and basically you know as
you know as most of you know the one of
the keep one of the central problems
additional physics is the face of is the
problem of phase transitions okay how
does electrics how does a change in the
parameter completely change the nature
of the interactions of a large
population of particles local
interactions in a way that is
quantitative qualitative okay so and
suddenly solve the directress right and
in 1989 it was sort of observed that
phase transitions are tantamount
coterminous equivalent in other words
what phase transitions really mean is
that one particular and demised
algorithm converges exponentially faster
okay and this was sort of you know an
incredible insight that change the field
if I change the field dramatically in
the following sense I mean oh that's in
some sense the greatest success story
that now there is a new field in which
physicists and computer scientists work
together okay and you have great
algorithms published by physicists okay
sort of you know and theorems in physics
proved by computer scientist okay you
know you have this very
active in harmonious sort of a reaction
the interaction between these two fields
that is going strong now and and and has
really change the discourse in
statistical mechanics another famous
example in 1982 it's a final wrote an
amazing paper called simulating physics
by computers okay so as I told you I
teach this class reading the classical
papers in computer science and I
consider this one of the great classics
of computer science okay because this
man said it better than in computer
science has how you what it entails to
simulate physics by computers okay and
then he noticed that there are some
systems namely quantum systems which
have need exponentially many parameters
to be described and amino there are two
ways to react right I mean no one is to
be conscientious computer scientists and
panic okay so are we gonna say you know
what am I going to do here or be Richard
Feynman and tell the question on its
head they say okay these are tough
systems but what we'll do build a
computer out of this okay and the point
is that in suing 10 years
what about physicists and most
remarkably computer scientists like like
kumaras irani my colleague here and and
Andy yeah
they created sort of you know were you
know they created the Turing machine for
quantum computations or you know the the
canonical example of quantum computation
and and I mean the rest the rest is
history and a huge part of this history
is the fact that the intractable problem
mentioned before okay that you cannot
factor integers can be solved in
polynomial time by quantum machines okay
all you have to do is input the thousand
bit number here thousand bits that's
three hundred digits that's ten lines
okay so I know it's on your on your
screen right I mean it's it's a lot you
create you you know you create slowly
from this number a superposition of two
to ten states to do thousand states you
handle you maintain the superposition
and you and you and you manipulate it
and after main maybe not thousand but
thousand cubed steps you measure it okay
and the measurement with high
probability is the factorization of the
number if it exists okay so this is sort
of an amazing result due to sure but
that sort of you know paid everybody pay
attention to the two random computers
and I like this quote because it tells
us that's not the point okay that's what
we do factoring is not the point
building powerful computers not the
point what the point of quantum
computation is is testing quantum theory
seeing if to what extent it generalizes
to many you know generalizes well to
many many particles okay and and and
this of course as you know is an ongoing
research and pepper that is that is so
we know it essentially it it it takes
through hoops the most prestigious
theory of the rivers and the hoops are
computational okay that's
all right so we talked about statistical
physics we talked about I'm gonna let me
out of physics fields so let's go to
social sciences and then life equilibria
all right I know what is a 'calibri
calibri basically our predictions in
economics all right I mean other
economists think that when you know when
a population of agents interact an
interesting way eventually very
cynically broom and this is our
prediction right I mean this is how this
is how how to predict and famously job
for Norman in 1928 proved that that
games have an equilibrium as long as
there are two player and zero-sum in
other words almost never okay you know
so so and it took another twenty
something years for for Nash to prove
that all games have one okay and and
this is the moment of birth of gainful
modern game theory okay so you know that
that basically the proof of Nash is sort
of made made game theory to a science
right amino end and not only that I mean
oh it's on some sense started all of
modern economics here is why because to
clever mathematicians Kenneth arrow and
Navarro in the blood a couple of years
later were inspired by Nash's proof and
proved the welfare theorems right amino
that all markets under assumptions have
price equilibria okay you know there are
prices that can clear all well-behaved
markets and you know in because of this
Roger Myerson law wrote wrote a few
years ago but the Nash equilibrium lies
at the foundations of modern economic
thought what he mean by meant by that
was this incident but also more
importantly the fact that a Nash
equilibrium allows is a license to any
economist
whether thinking about the market there
institutions are designing or any
situation in which agents interact in
interesting ways to say okay let's see
what happens at equilibrium all right
and and so by the way this is this this
slide has 20 words or less and has four
Nobel Prizes okay it's not not not
easily do yeah okay and the surprise is
that the Nash equilibria which is
intractable problem right I'm going and
so we had a nice very nice
dialogue before right I mean oh that
what does a big up with this what does
intractability mean in practice okay and
all with you okay I totally agree but in
practice intractability may not mean
much okay what I said before okay what
Meyerson said is that the Nash
equilibrium is a theoretical problem is
a theoretical tool okay in other words
what I'm saying is that it interact a
bit result says that Nash's theorem is
equivalent to saying that almost all
games have a Nash equilibrium okay and
believe me if Nash's theorem said that
the world of economics would be
completely different today
okay it's important that all games have
a massacre it's theoretical important
that all games have a magical it okay to
put it in the wise words of my
curriculum Kemal Jane if your laptop
can't find it neither can the market
every time I I saw these poor economies
I get into trouble I get into a long
discussion at the end of which we agree
okay the market is not a laptop but it's
a bunch of you know
but it's the same thing good so let's go
to finally to life science alright know
and and and I'll tell you just two words
about some work that we did with about
on evolution so you know Jacques Monod
said that evolution is funny because
it's you know in some sense among all
scientific fields has the highest ratio
of people who think they understand
something about it
versus those who actually do okay and
frankly in a bad day this ratio looks
infinite okay so for example I don't
know if you are aware but 150 years
after this this 160 years now after
after this wonderful book we don't know
what is the role of sex okay I know all
of you have heard the theory and that
your your favorite theory experts agree
that none of them explains why sex is so
predominant while there you look around
you are all different for me know if
selection is a point why are we all
different why haven't we converge to
some great phenotype these are values
optimizing something okay that's sort of
a theoretical question but but it has
been torturing evolutionary theories
since the inception of mathematical
evolution or ratio since the days of
Fisher right and Haldane
okay and Fisher had an idea of you know
some cuddling famously work to work on
finding it the apana function for
evolution but we don't know okay so let
me show you a result okay
no before here is how a third edition
will teach TC purity theoretical bitter
scientists would ask the question what
algorithm could have done all this okay
polish in a mere
steps why trivia theorem is a number of
generations since the dawn of life okay
and trillion steps may sound a lot of
steps but your your your cell phone has
done a television step since the
beginning of my talk okay and it has not
accomplished much okay excellent
okay so he's asking a great question I'm
not going to get into it is this the
right thing what is their eyes oh is
this the right of or this is times the
right number of species all these times
a number of organisms or these times the
number of cells in these organisms okay
what is the what is the real what is the
real laboratory okay and I am one of
these people who believe that the
laboratory is the generation okay and
I'll show you what I mean I'll show you
why I think so okay good so let me I
know so you know so this is this is
where I'm I'm you know I'm starting to
catch on my equation credit okay so you
know I I know I assumed I shouldn't put
too many equations away but but but here
is one I want to you see this is very
simplified case you can do it in more
complicated cases but suppose that you
have evolution of haploid population we
are diploid in the week selection regime
this means that that selection is not
dramatic
okay so selection forces or dramatic
they are like smooth okay and this is
something that that evolutionary
biologists have not no trouble admitting
and we have the gene just you know we're
focusing on two alleles of the oil with
that one gene and Tobit solids okay
and now consider what is what are these
numbers this is the frequency of allele
1 as generation T plus 1 I guess ok so
the allele 2 is 1 minus X T okay right
and basically I'm telling you how this
this quantity goes from one generation
to the next
okay and this equation we wrote it for
the first time but it was really you
know there are there are thick thick
volumes with mathematics on evolution
right and this equation was three
algebraic manipulations away from from
equations that were already there okay
but once you see it you know once we saw
it
sorry my voice is breaking so you know I
heard the mesh you know my co-author say
now I have faith in evolution you see
why so what I'm saying so so the
question is that so what base guide says
the following that the frequency of a
little over the first allele is okay
sorry yes so you want to see this
yeah okay yes is the s is a selection
strength sorry and not assuming that is
very small okay because there's a weak
selection as a resume you know what one
is XT is the previous generation right
and what is F F is the relative fitness
of allele in the present genetic
environment I'm saying the following
that the organism has an environment
around its fitness depends on it
but also have this this gene has also
genetic environment around it the other
genes that interact with okay and they
create another Fitness the relative
fitness which is this one not
necessarily because because you know
they will sample zero eventually because
you are dividing by the sorry if you
wish yeah sounds really no okay okay so
that's the equation and I mean oh we
derived it but it's like a really high
school job do you derive it is very
intuitive sort of you know and and you
can get it out of the mouth of the
method people had people had okay there
is sort of a very complex theories or
you know of page-long equations you know
and if you if you if you specialized for
this regime okay you get this equation
that's one same and if you look at this
equation sort of you know your my my jaw
drops you know why because this is
multiplicative update please multiple
family really weights up with okay so
okay so it turns out that evolution use
multiplicative weights okay and sort of
there is much more
if you ask yourself not the following
question okay so every generation this
gene has to select XT plus 1 okay and
selects it this way
why what is it optimizing by selecting
it this way okay and here is what is
optimizing okay this is the potential
function variable new function that this
gene is optimizing okay and it is it has
two terms one term is is sort of you
know the sum over all previous
generations of the differential fitness
of the first G from the second few gene
their differential relative fitness and
the second one is a huge factor times
the entropy of the distribution okay all
right so I mean let me explain why why I
find this video first of all it is a
[ __ ] explicit function which genes
seem to be optimizing okay and this is
this is interesting
number two it has a fitness term and
then it has an entropy term this means
that the genes when optimizing the
reaction to the genetic environment they
are mindful of diversity okay if they
don't want to call him all right let me
know they they give a lot of weight to
the entropy of the hood celebration okay
so nothing more just want to remind you
the question is the four questions I
asked what I'll call you can have done
this in a mere trillion steps I think
now I know entropy is amazing sort of is
the Shannons measure of diversity okay
it's it's the sum of the logarithm or
reverse probabilities as you know is
expected the industry location or the
inverse probability and it's basically
its maximum when it's 50/50 and
and it's sort of the standard measure of
diversity and so what is the role of sex
my biology quarters don't like me to say
that but I'm convinced that the role of
sex is to enable the multiplicative wait
Sal good ok why all this this diversity
well I don't know but but gene simply be
mindful of the first is evolution of
demising something I don't know either
but I think that I know what genes are
optimized yes yes very much very much
very much because because basically
these wants to keep it close to half and
this wants to please keep it to don't
either 0 1 so you know whatever whatever
whatever whatever is the sign of this
recently right yeah okay there's a
company there is a clear combination of
loggerheads well the temperature is this
okay then you know because the more time
goes on this term will become bigger and
it's going I understand understand but
but about here it's here okay I mean
prove it you know
freshman campus yeah you know you just
you just you know kuhn-tucker you know
but okay okay good now so and now I'm
going to tell you about TCS in the brain
in the last 15 minutes as promised so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
about my work and it's not because you
know both going talked a little about it
yesterday
it's not because I think it's it's it's
you should know about it but because I
think it's you know it's it's an
interesting specimen of the form how
would a computer scientist or you know
will do you know first start working on
the brain all right so all right so this
is what we're all interested in okay in
fact so you know I like to call it a
sunset from the Berkeley Hills question
all right let me know call these
questions here's what I mean but every
time I see this this view what comes to
my mind is why doesn't everybody stop
what they're doing and come here to
watch this so when I think about the
brain I'm in the same mood okay you know
why why why are people working with
something else and given my background
and because I want to believe that the
answer once we find it it's going to be
at least partly computational I wouldn't
to answer this question how does one
think computationally about the brain
and the point is that good people have
worked on this what I've thought about
this I mean Turing have been thinking
about the mind
all his life okay so for Newman towards
the end of his life I wrote an amazing
book which I highly recommend you know I
read it after after Wolfgang recommended
to me and it's eye-opening okay so you
know it's eye-opening how somebody you
know in the 1950 would have this insight
about the brain so here is one inside
the way the brain works may be
characterized by less logical analytical
depth that were not that were normally
used okay so you know if you're trying
if you are hoping to find your favorite
sophisticated algorithm the brain sort
of you know remember for Neiman right
let me know that that it's that it's I
think he's right on the spot
less valiant professor at Harvard the
founder of learning theory he he worked
in the 1990s on the brain and came up
with a very interesting model came up
with a well-developed theory wrote a
book circles of the mind but here I'm
going to quote a beautiful a beautiful
sentence of his that a computational
view of the brain is both possible and
essential okay so you know and he
elsewhere says that one of the founders
of sort of you know brain theory of
neuroscience would be surprised that
there are not many competing theories of
the computational theories of the drain
right now okay okay and of course David
Marr a lot of people talked about him
you know the way and the way I
transliterate his program in modern
computer prediction is that he wants us
to think about specs by which I mean the
input-output behavior we want the city
we want two weeks book we know the
system has hardware what is what are the
physical elements that are implicated
and the algorithm how are what are the
processes well by this these these these
physical elements are put together to
achieve these specifications and let's
remember for Newman that we should
expect this algorithm to vanish often
okay so ignore to to be so simple that
it barely deserves the name are good
okay okay so let's start to the specs
okay so you know I'm so and and I'm
going to describe the you of something
that that also about Convention and
and I'm going to use sort of you know a
running example that is not accurate in
terms of what of what of but I'm you
know it captures the essence of what
they found so they they let's say you
know the to keep it to keep the story
simple you know they they recorded from
a few dozen neurons from a dozen or so
patients but let's focus on one one
subject in one Europe and they showed
them about a couple of hundred in a very
strict regime capital protocol is a
couple of hundred of pictures and this
particular neuron fired every time the
the Eiffel Tower was shot okay you show
other well-known sites nothing
every time the Eiffel Tower is shown
inspires you showing deep you know you
used to be our president remember yeah
so so does pile okay okay they Photoshop
Obama in front of the Eiffel Tower
okay and the probably do it in more art
we'll wait an idle here okay and and of
course the neuron beautifully fires
because it sees the Eiffel Tower time
they show that a tower of course it
fires Forbidden City nothing Obama
so you know my voice cracks right I mean
Oh
this guy has learned that Obama has been
to the Eiffel Tower and you discover
this experimentally okay okay so I think
I think you know I like this pecs okay
you know so these are these are the
specs and the question is what is the
hardware and what is the algorithm and
and and this is joining work with with
with the Wolfgang Robert both at grads
and Santos vampire Georgia Tech so let's
talk about hardware so they recorded
from from a few dozen out of out of many
10 10 million euros medial temporal lobe
in every subject
they showed about a hundred pictures of
a million persons and places with
repetitions and they just they had the
about ten hits okay which is a lot of it
okay because these are many neurons a
few pictures right so just about the
only thing I can explain this is that
each memory is represented by an
assembly of many neurons and that's not
a new idea I know it's an old idea whose
time has come
help of course mentioned it in 1949 and
and this is one of the putative ways of
understanding how memories are are
stalled both putative both both both
help and and other researchers they
conjecture that such assemblies are this
actually and very interesting thing to
to test experimentally highly connected
therefore stable it is somehow formed by
sensory stimuli probably in response to
some attention mechanism and every time
we think of this debris
most of these neurons fire okay
it's just a cautionary note that they
stick their needle and MTO it's very
close to hippocampus 2 which does
one-shot learning and they also took the
patients and showed them pictures like
the test pictures the before they've
been their final thing so it's turned in
that they burned in the the picture
member it wasn't there before they had
their test sample but it wasn't that one
sorry if you didn't if you just stick
the needle there and and didn't have the
pretest you would have said seen nothing
but the hippocampus has done one shot so
basically they prepare the patient with
a sample of pictures like the ones they
were going to test they created this
memory on the floor it's not like that
it's not like you could do that think
from a cold start
what is he okay it's true it's true that
beats through that that that before
before recording they presented the
present and sort of the depiction of
energy I agree you know also it's true
that this closely hippocampus but it's
not close enough I mean no they they
record it from any from any areas that
of MPL that are not important that are
far from being poor campus and I'm not
sure where where the where the
Association urine okay I I understand
okay okay so I understand that you know
I am also you know I read the paper so
here I'm skeptical of all mobile
experiments right I mean oh so so but
let me know but but I like this and I
want to work on that okay that's that's
my you know then and of course words of
caution are available so you're saying
that probably after some I am awake
among you do the same experiment with
the same people it will not have the
soul but that's for sure that's for sure
that's for sure I mean oh it's going to
be completely different go yet I mean
that's definitely for sure yeah I
totally believe that
go lower and empty and in in for
temporal cortex then you find hundreds
of thousands of neurons aboard of course
yes yes yes totally I totally agree
yeah and what what I think and what what
are these community things is that these
are projections from the infrared intro
temporal cortex now reformed it from the
place where whole object learning
happens there are projections to to to
the MTL to the medial temporal lobe okay
that this is what this is what their
current explanation is not useful but if
you blow out the hippocampus and destroy
that connection then you can carry on
conversations you just can't learn any
anything okay right of course of course
yes yeah yes yes okay funny thing I mean
oh this this this usually are called you
know assembly cells or go the memory
cells are called Jennifer Aniston cells
okay you know so all right so and so we
have we have a conjecture about five
hardware who have aspects we want to
have an algorithm how our assemblies
form and how does the situation happen
okay so and as I told I think won't be
the beginning so you know we we like to
prove things and so we want to find a
very simple model where you can prove
that both learning of memories stable
memories can happen and associations
okay so what what time you know and now
this is the infrared temporal quarters
and this is this is the MTL what we
conjecture is is that this thing fires
repeatedly and in response
an assembly emerges in the in the medial
temporal lobe okay and also that if two
memories like Obama I felt I repeatedly
together then these corresponding
assemblies are going to creep a little
closer together another law okay and we
know these people who are lucky to catch
a cell in that overlap okay that that
that went from eyeful only to eyford and
Obama okay
and in fact in in simulations by by the
both Congress book group over the you
know the recurrent neural network model
support the conjecture right let me know
but I told you we want to prove it in
fact something else supports the
conjecture it's a story that that
Richard Axel who wrote in a paper in the
discussion of the table and the C story
is the following I me know the stories
about how Excel things that that uh
assemblies forming the period from
peripheral cortex of mouse or even an
old structure that is connected Rolf
action in response to firing from the
from the olfactory bulb for a particular
odorant and here is here is what here is
he what his narrative is an odorant may
cause a small subset of neurons in the
pitiful quarter cortex to fire this
small fraction of cells will then
generate sufficient recurrent
excitations to recruit a larger
population of neurons inhibition
triggered by this activity will prevent
further firing although will restrict
fire in the extreme some cells could
receive an Africa and people to fire
without receiving initial input in other
words what what what axel says that
there are some lucky cells that get a
lot of projection from from from
the olfactory bulb but then they recruit
new ones and there is sort of you know a
balance in the final assembly between
born rich and new recruits and I'll
describe the mathematical model here we
use and we have supposed to have two
large effects that are excitatory
neurons and this is the sensory cortex
let's say and the memory area or MDL
there are synapses that project from the
sensory cortex to the MPL and fro and
recurrent connections and they form a
random GNP directed graphs like the
graph I described before we assume
discrete time because because we want a
very simple model that can prove
something about we said that we say that
the presentation of the stimulus is at a
small set of sensory cortex neurons fire
for a small number of steps this is this
is the eiffel tower assembly in the
infrared temporal cortex firing okay and
then at each time T after that I set a
sub T of K memory area neurons that have
the largest nap take input from either
AC or recurrently from or the memory
area fire and you know now we are using
sort of you know a very heavy assumption
that that we are we are selecting the KA
largest neurons but we can also show
that the same with the same conclusion
can be done if you have a hibbett or a
population that that that the reacts are
faster and you assume that synapses have
a very simple rule of heavier plasticity
which basically says that the very
simple thing that if at time T cell I
fires and the time T plus one cell J
fires the weight of synapse i J
increases by some amount okay
because less than less than their friend
oh boy this is what this is what our
demise not going to do yes yes right yes
you're sorry the only randomness we have
here is the randomness of the graph
that's the initial random exactly yeah
yeah of course yeah plasticity means
that the way you know the graph stays
the same all the time the weights change
but that's important that's important
yeah that's important right right
exactly
so what you can prove
I'm not going to bother you the reserve
it's already know but you can prove the
precise narrative of assembly formation
in Excel table okay and we also can
prove that after the sequence of
presentation I felt memory Obama memory
then I fell on Obama together then I
fell down Obama a small man on vines in
set of cells in the eiffel assembly will
also respond to Obama and vice versa
and of course all of this was hyperbole
all right so stronger results you get if
you assume a more a more elaborate model
of connectivity no just GMP but
something called GMT plus plus which is
a following that I told you let's say
that the the chance that we need to note
the chance that there is a directed edge
this way is 1% now conditioned on that
the chance of the reverse one you know
this called the reciprocity it has been
observed in song at all 15 years ago but
also in many subsequent papers
experiment then the chance that there is
a
never going back he's not one person but
temporary no 5% 6% temperature and also
sometimes called triangle completion
that given that these two synapses exist
then the chance that the trial is
completed is is also very high and it
turns out that there is a reason why
these give better results and watch the
reason is the following
but if you take two cells in this
assembly in the formed X in the memory
they look like random cells right now we
know from all points of view except that
they all are likely to have high
connectivity with these guys okay and if
you think about that there is birthday
paradox okay there is a birthday part of
phenomenon which says that it's very
likely that they have a common ancestor
and once you have that then they're more
likely to be very con much more likely
to be connected okay so that's this is
sort of one thing that makes what makes
it the next okay so let me let me finish
with two questions of many and let me
know two things that I'm very curious
about I told you one can you know our
assemblies indeed more densely connected
than random set and memory area in
general can cope in a tutorial
completion that biases such as risk Oh
stand trial completion be a crucial part
of the way the brain works I guess the
trivial answer is yes because otherwise
they won't be there but about amino so
you know I would like to understand what
is there you know what how they are
created and what is what is what is I'll
use and can't mechanism a cannon similar
to the one described here be a part of
the brain circuit for building syntax
trees okay so I don't know if you are
following this but there has been an
explosion of evidence of experimental
evidence in the last maybe two years
suggest you know so if you read this I
mean oh if I read this six months ago I
would ask the speaker do you really
but when we talk we built brains but we
build trees in the left hemisphere okay
and but now I'm inclined to believe it
okay so you know and my question is you
know I'll be delighted to give you sorry
syntax trees are what linguists do in
order to understand a sentence
okay and they're explicit trees of
degree two and and and and there is
growing evidence but something like that
happens when we talk and when we hear
and we know that you know there are
suspects areas implicated and so on
being Broca's area for example parts of
Broca's area is where is where the
internal nodes of these trees seem to be
[Music]
random but building something that
random exactly yeah yeah yeah you said
it right so to finish we are we think
algorithmically
where mathematicians in health okay so
you like proving theorems we know about
complexity and randomness and we know
about you know we don't know the cartoon
complex do we know the real meaning of
complexity okay and we like to explore
interesting areas and learn new tricks
and look forward to interacting with you
learning
[Music]
the last example that you give what is
special about the urges for any
initialization of the gravity so why not
so what happens if you start with
everything connected to everything
everybody connects it to everything okay
I like to work with friends and random
graphs are my friends okay
no and I don't know how else to say okay
so you know my abs are so absolutely
absolutely absolutely the special
property is called the Bernoulli
distribution and it's flexibility of its
approximations searching into my soul
okay I give this on facial depravity for
teachers can be a stronger than burning
that's not as bad as as as as as
consciousness but it's almost okay
so all right deep nets okay that you
know brain scientists and deep net
engineers and scientists know that there
are huge differences okay if you want to
focus on one is that the deep nets
no need equals synaptic weights going
forward so when the algorithm finishes
we need all the synaptic weights
converge to whatever they're supposed to
paper if it does any like layer
structure so out of the graph so what
you know what what we find very
interesting that happens is that there
is a stable assembly for the other one
so every time so you know some of these
insane neurons fire this assembly will
would catch fire okay so you know so
there is there is a paramount memory you
know we know that nothing is permanent
and so you know but but but this this
this is formed and also we know that
nothing the bringing will be you know it
will be much more chaotic noisy wet and
so on so you know but but this is like
an existence theorem okay so know that
that there is a we you know there is a
way you know they say the same with
with the simulation of the results in
birth control I know there is a way
so no for this to happen okay and who
knows what happens the reality so no but
but but maybe something like this that
very distance approximation of this may
be happy
okay just thanks very much 131